hi everyone so today I will talk about
the fine tuning methods for text image
models
and modern text to image models such as
table diffusion that lead to imagine
Carlo
is a major breakthrough in contemporary
generative AI topic
and this is a very
crucial to fine-tune them to uh to adopt
them to the different use cases
so
today I will present several fine-tuning
methods we'll start from the uh
discussion about the text image models
high level architecture after it we will
talk about
models fine-tuning Concept in general
after it I will present the five
different methods for the fine tuning
we will summarize them in a summary and
then we'll perform the Q a
so
first of all Let's uh talk about the
models architecture yeah the this is a
very large amount of different text to
image models on the plate for now
uh but all these models have
shared and very
common high level architecture so in
this slide you can see the general
architecture for all text to image
models
so we're starting from the text we're
feeding this text to the text encoder
typically is one of the this large
language models such as clip or
something like that after it we will get
the text embeddings yeah
and fit this text and links to the image
decoder in a majority of cases the image
decoder for now is a diffusion model
and finally get the image yeah so this
is a high level architecture of almost
every text to image model
um
and our main goal is that for example we
want to teach our text to image model
yeah our pre-trained text image model to
generate this particular kind of dog
yeah this is a very specific type of dog
that is not represented in a text to
image model and we try to teach this
model to identify and we're able to
generate this particular kind of Tokyo
so we have a new data set with the New
Concept this dog
represented as a image text pairs yeah
there's several image text pairs yeah
you can see that we are feeding it to
the model and try to teach this model to
generate
this
dog in different contexts here it's not
necessarily to be uh some subject driven
concept so it can be some style or even
some large group of Concepts so it's not
necessarily the one but for Simplicity
let's assume that
in this presentation we will talking
about this simple case
Okay so
the next
uh slide is about that okay we have this
new data set with the New Concept in it
and uh the Sim the most simple setup
with the
um
for training of this model we will have
this shape yeah so we have a new data
set where get from this new data set the
text and image
and uh yeah fit the text to the text
encoder get the text emboding with the
image decoder get the image calculate
the loss between images and back
propagate it to the image decoder and
text encoder respectively yeah so this
is a the simplest possible setup but
unfortunately this type of fine tuning
it's not working very well with this
contemporary large models
because of various reasons yeah we have
five large Reasons by this particular
case is not working for this large
models
so the first problem is a data set size
so typically this text to image models
is trained on a very large data sets
yeah very very large
at least half billion image pairs in
general yeah this is a one of the
smallest number
in Industry so this is super and for
retraining it without the overfitting we
need at least uh the same magnitude of
data yeah so
the second one is a quality yeah this is
a quality level of results after finding
in this case if we just give our data
and feed it to the network and train it
uh in almost every case we will have
pretty pure quality because it's
instantly over fit this date set because
typically even in a commercial scale
industry the data set is not that large
yes so for example the 10 million is a
very small data set for for this type of
models
and the the Third
uh problem is a forgetting so this is a
very specific type of overfitting
related to the large models it's called
catastrophic forgetting when we're
trying to teach the model the concepts
and it forgets everything that he'd
learned before so if he's a pre-trained
model and we have a very large amount of
Concepts encapsulated in it and it just
forget all these things and become a
very weak model yeah so this is a amount
of how much model for gets after a fine
tune yeah of course it is the speed
because
for training of this type of models
especially for with the large data sets
require a very large amount of resources
and very large amount of time
and the last but not least this is a
memory consumption because the storage
consumption this is a pretty big problem
in the industry because
this large text to image models in
average is very very large so it's take
like five on three gigabytes at least
yes so if you are
uh trying to train different model for
different models for different cases you
will have a very large amount of
models with the this this amount of
space here and the memory storage
consumption will be very high
so
uh so this simplest method is not
working for for our case and we're
defined the five different metrics how
to evaluate the further methods so
let's go to the
methods so in general we have very large
amount of different fine tuning methods
it's very Hot Topic in uh in a
generative AI for now and almost every
day and the communities created
something new in this topic so but for
today I will discussing the five
different topics five different methods
for today and
the first one is a regularized fine
tuning so the idea of regularized fine
tuning it's very
um
very easy so
they try to
avoid this forgetting yeah this is a one
of the major problems so the first
um
uh the first Target to solve for the
scientist will be this forgetting part
and they design a very simple system
when they just add some regularization
data set to our new data set typically
this regularization data set is sampled
from the original training set of the
model is for example for the stable
diffusion this is a sample from the line
yeah
and mix this regularized data set with a
new data set and train this wall model
on this both data sets simultaneously
yeah so in this case it's obviously will
prevent some overfitting and forgetting
the
and in general yeah this setup is box
and it's several implementation in a
public community so one of the famous
band this ever dream setup that you can
find the GitHub
uh so
uh in this case this small this
particular method is working only with
the middle and large size data sets
because it's still large scale fine
tuning yeah so but this large data set
is not that large that before so for
example it starts working with this this
10 million five million Etc yeah the
quality is very high because it's still
uh High scale large fine tuning of the
all parts of the model
forgetting it's still there it's uh
impossible to avoid the forgetting at
all so this is for getting some parts
but it's very few things yeah
uh the speed is slow because at least we
are adding some new part of data to our
data so the data is at least doubled in
this case and yeah it's obviously that
we have us we still have slow training
process yeah and the storage is still
high because we are fine tuning the text
encoder and image decoder and need to
store it after the retraining okay so
this is the first setup
uh before we will go to the next ones we
need to introduce some uh One More
Concept to our data set
so we we need to add to our concept the
the special keyword that we call Unique
identifier in this case is this brackets
V yeah
and in this case you can see that we are
generally if we we want from a model to
generate this particular dog where
specifically specified this dog with
this V unique identifier the idea is
that if you want to gener to teach
models something very specific and the
distribution is much smaller than the
original distribution of model you can
fix the
um the actual part of the Latin space
with the introducing of special keyword
for this for this data yeah so it's
obviously narrowing down the
the possibility of the system in terms
of like this special keyboard can be
very wide because yeah in this case it's
just useless but uh it's narrowing down
the use case but give us several
advantages that I will present in the
next slides so the first system that
used this unique identifier as an
advantage is a dream boot by Google
so the idea is following
um
this is a very similar setup to the
regular fine tuning the difference is
only these two things yeah the first
thing is uh we're introducing this
unique identifier yeah and attaching it
to our data set you know some sort of
way so typically it's in the beginning
of the text yeah or in the end of the
text
and replacing the regularized data set
with more specific data set in this
particular case with the dog we are
replacing our regularization data set
with the data set of dogs but not this
dog that we're trying to uh learn yeah
so the other dogs
uh and the all other things is a pretty
same to the regularized fine tuning so
these two
um
these two things is allowing us to have
this Dreamboat model that
typically uh have following
characteristics yeah the dead set size
that is required for the training is a
small and it's not supported the large
data set it's uh
become yeah it's not working for the
large data sets and typically after the
hundreds of images it's starting doing
some artifacts so this is working only
for small data sets because of this
unique identifier and some specifics of
the construction the quality is very
high so in Industry this is a while one
of the
uh good quality methods for fine tuning
the forgetting is a three things yeah
still not very much more than in a
previous case in general but less than
the uh the fine tuning itself the row of
fine tuning yeah the speed is a middle
because we still have some additional
data set in this case
attached to the or to the model and the
storage is still high because we fine
tune the text encoder and image decoder
and need to store the weights yeah
uh so the next
major topic that about the fine tuning
this is a detect show inversion yeah
textual inversion is very interesting
idea when
we're trying to shift this idea of
fine-tuning of the models to fine-tuning
of text and learning so the idea is
following where
instead of training the large models
yeah this text encoder and image decoder
we are trying to optimize the text
embedding of the specific unique
identifier so what this means in terms
of
weapon space so with in this case we're
just assuming that our text to image
model is General enough to capture all
the information in our new data set that
basically we're assuming that this model
is already contains this particular type
of dog in it but we just need to find it
yeah so this is a actual idea so this
optimization of this text damaging is a
thus searching in Latin space basically
so we're trying to find this concept
that our DOT Concept in the Latin space
of the text encoder
so this is a one of the most interesting
one because it's uh
uh yeah it's some paraging shift from
the other two ones so in this case uh
this works with the small data sets even
with very very small so we'll even work
with the one image
the quality is still pretty high
slightly less than Dreamboat but still
high
the forgetting in this case is very good
in terms of like did we can't forget
anything by definition in this case
because we are not training the text
encoder and imaging coder yeah it's just
impossible to forget something so we're
just introducing and just finding the
concept in in the model so in this case
we're forget almost nothing
so in terms of speed it is a middle so
middle because you are still need to uh
uh forward the actual text encoder image
decoder so this is just time consuming
because this is a large model but yeah
do you you
it's significantly faster than the
previous one because you just need to
update the gradients only for this text
yeah
uh and the memory consumption is very
low and in this case is I think the
lowest one from our today presentation
so it's very very low it's can even take
several kilobytes it's very very low
amount of data yet to store
uh yeah this is about the texture
conversion so
the next one this is a Laura so lower
rank adaptation yeah the Laura is not
something new in emotional learning and
deep learning itself so this is a pretty
old method for training optimization for
the for the optimization of training of
large models the only difference of and
only novelty of the method is that they
the open source Community
adopt uh adapt this low rank adaptation
to different uh text image models such
as stable diffusion
Etc yeah so in this case the uh they
introduce two tricks yeah it's very
similar approach to the raw fine tuning
but instead of training the text encoder
and image decoder
we're just adding new layers using this
residual connection trick
to the models and uh
train only these layers yeah so we're
freezing the entire text encoder entire
image decoder and train only our audit
layers yeah
and we in this case it's obvious that we
are adding the count of parameters so
we're just adding some layers it means
that we are
multiply the amount of weights and we
will have the pretty large weight
mattress so in this case uh the the one
the the final and most important trick
is that they try to
um they actually
factorize this weight matrices to the
two matrixes so this is a conventional
Matrix factorization and using some of
the methods for Matrix factorization so
uh with the and in this case they try to
approximate this weight Matrix with the
two low rank matrices yeah so uh in this
case you can see this is a four by five
mattresses we are factorized by four by
two and two by five in this particular
case but don't uh gain very much amounts
of weight after this operation because
uh yeah we are just just gained only two
weights yeah because the five by four is
a 20 and that this is a 18 year so but
in in a real case this weight mat axis
is way larger and the factorization is
again for us a very large amount of
where a large amount of weight so
basically
in this case we'll decrease the amount
of Weights very dramatically yeah
so this type of
fine tuning is working with almost any
data set so it supports a small one the
large one the middle one so it's just
depends from the your rank parameter so
you can adopting your actual setup to
capture the uh
the the data no matters the the the size
yeah the quality is a middle uh because
we're restricting the Our
Generation possibility two ways so we
are trained only the audit layers but uh
but also where uh decreasing the amount
of Weights significantly and this is a
of course uh lowering our quality in
general it's not necessary a bad quality
but this is a less than the in the
previous cases yeah
uh so about the forgetting it still
forgets something but not very uh
uh very much so this uh again few things
and in terms of speed
uh it's very fast because you are doing
this trick with the low rank adaptation
so you're optimizing just very small
matrices and this is a typically uh much
faster than the training of the actual
two models it's very dependent from your
rank but actually yeah it's give us the
acceleration
and the storage is low because you are
need to store only these two factorized
matrices
on the disk so this is a two very small
mattresses yeah in this case
okay
uh and the next one
uh the last but not least this is a the
very similar idea to the Laura but the
difference is that we're replacing all
these things related to this weight
matrices with the some neural network
that we call hyper Network that is try
to predict the weights for these added
layers yeah
and we're training only this hyper
Network yeah
this method is much flexible than the
Laura but also this method is much more
complicated in terms of Maintenance and
in terms of
finding the good optimal parameters
because you need to design this hyper
Network typically and sometimes it's not
easy but in general you it's obvious
that
uh you can create the hyper Network that
is much more uh regularized in terms of
uh
in terms of weight generation than than
the method lore that I present
previously because uh you can add some
losses to this hyper Network to uh to
prevent some uh weight explosion Etc yes
so you have a more fine-grade control in
this case
and this method is also support any data
set type it's just depend from dependent
from your net hyper Network size the
quality is the same uh to Laura for
getting it's also the same so you are
forgetting few things
at the speed is a middle because in this
case your optimizing the network instead
of optimizing the just weight mattress
Matrix so this is a some computational
overhead typically in the hyper Network
and the storage is also middle because
you are not because typically the hyper
networks is slightly
have more capacity and more weights than
the low rank weights before yeah so this
is some middle case
uh okay
so
this is our summary
so you can see all the methods
represented together and all the our
metrics
and you can see that uh in general we
uh we don't have the clear winner there
because uh each
model is somehow unique and support
different type of things and basically
the you can use each of them for your
specific use case it's very dependent
from your particular use case yeah so
all this method is pretty useful and all
this method is used in a community in
the industry so
um but yeah you can see the some models
that have some weaknesses and advantages
yeah so you can compare them
uh and choose the best one for your use
case
uh yeah
so from my side so you can from the
Quran day
foreign
questions
yep my question is related to the
regular right ones you name uh we were
using two data sets right we were taking
uh some part of the training data set
it's cold today
we were taking some part of the training
data set and mixing it with the new data
set right yes and for generating new
images uh the image decoder takes in
account the gradients of the text
embeddings right yes so if we add some I
don't know other images rather than the
dog images wouldn't their gradients be
two different wouldn't it
kinda mess up with the generating
process yeah it's very good question
this is a typically
controlled by this regularization loss
weight yeah so you can if your data set
actually is very different from your new
data set but you still need to preserve
these parts of the
distribution of the original text
encoder for example you need to add the
dogs but you want to make sure that the
all other parts of the distribution of
the original model is not harmed you you
can add the very large amount of data
from the original training set from the
this line that's set in in the case of
stable diffusion it's possible but in
this case you just need to do some
tricks in this regularization lot so you
need to tune the weight and maybe
balance this to data set in a batch for
example you can create your badge based
on the the equal number of samples from
this this data set yeah you can do the
tricks to avoid the
the ignoring of your original concept
that you try to learn uh can we also
control the
values of gradients like make the
gradient the directions of the new data
sets images gradient speaker
yeah sure you can control it with the
debates yeah
yes
what is
about our fitting of that model because
I know that a data set size is small
it's actually 10 or 50 5 10 samples and
is it true that the quality will be high
because of the overfitting on that data
set that you are given to him yeah the
the the in case of Dreamboat our magic
trick to avoid the the forgetting is
actually this unique identifier so the
idea is that if we are fixing the
specific part of the distribution with
the sum name where most likely not harm
the other part of the distribution it's
not uh exactly true so this is a
assumption but in in general this works
pretty well so in case of Dreamboat it's
the overfitting is still still there
also you can see that this is many
things not a few things yeah there's a
this forget the many things yeah uh but
the this introduction of this unique
identifier is typically prevent us to uh
to harm all other uh parts of the
distribution just because we are we're
trying to optimize specific place
of the distribution yeah so this just
our magic trick that help us but yeah
the remote is not very good uh as a
general fine tuning method so you can't
uh fine-tune the
the text to image model with dreamboot
to achieve some very generic generation
things typically you are trying to learn
some specific concept like like dog like
uh let's like just subject driven
concept or you're just trying to learn
the style related Concept in this case
it's somehow works so it's in the
internet you can find a very large
amount of different models created by
Dreamboat and for the this particular
use cases that they work pretty well but
if you are going to the some specific
parts of the distribution you can find
that basically they forget the uh some
things from the original distribution so
this is a method to add some small
Concepts to the model yeah and is it
fair to compare this model with the
other ones such as Laurel or Hippo
network no the the ID is following the
the you can see the inner Laura and
hypernetes in and in a regularized fine
tuning we don't have this unique
identifier thing so it's not necessary
to uh this is a much more generic uh
fine tunic methods than the Dreamboat
and texture inversion yeah do you know
about lens AI
is it
is
either as dream boot yeah they've uh
yeah they use Dreamboat to personalize
uh your avatar yeah so they yeah
actually use Dreamboat
yes can you talk more about this
indificator because I don't understand
clearly what is it because is it a world
yes this is a special kind of word so
the this is a specific trigger word that
we are giving to this text embedding and
yeah we are this is a very specific word
and typically is a some artificial word
because if we're choosing some real word
in this case for example if we're just
just assume that this is a dog yeah just
assigned to this concept the dog keyword
it will be problem because you will you
will
uh intersect the the original
distribution of stable diffusion for
example yeah and uh you will have some
interconnected associations in the model
yeah and it's not the title label it's
doggy no no no this is a some artificial
words typically this is one of the most
popular one this is yeah this is a very
rare word that is not appears in a real
sentences and they
give this special keyword to the this
specific concept yeah yeah this is some
artificial word to avoiding this random
associations in the model yeah this is
some artificial word and this type of
words is also very uh common so you can
just write some think bit brackets and
some letters Etc and this works yeah
okay and it's a good idea to take some
not only one identificator you can make
it uh this is a much more complicated
situation when you are trying to teach
your model to identify several different
uh Concepts it's possible of course even
with the Dreamboat but this is a much
more complicated case yeah this is some
maybe it's uh you need some uh more
research in this case because sometimes
several Concepts can be to can be can't
be distinguished from each other yeah
and yeah yeah this is a can be a very
mess yeah sometimes yeah this is a why
typically the communities were training
this Dreamboat model using only one
keyword yes so you are just at the one
word and one concept and just it yeah
because in other case in a multi-concept
way this is a much more complex get the
situation yeah but it's possible yes
definitely
yep
yes sure
but here by the small length
approximation but I'll just only give us
optimization in terms of student memory
or we get better
good question yeah the this also give us
the regulation because we're yeah we're
lowering amount of weights and this is a
means that we are have large chance to
overfit and yeah this is a some some
sort of Regulation yeah and this is a
also affect the quality
yeah this is a true
speed here in terms of then go to the
last Slide the hyper Network
yeah this one okay
yeah it's just the differences because
the Dreamboat is working with the small
data sets this is just difference
because of the Dreamboat is supported
only the small data sets yeah this is
just because the data set size and the
speed is correlated things
okay
with the differentiation of these
approaches and which one would you
recommend if we are dealing with ultra
high resolution
uh okay yeah in this case if you are
want to generate uh in general all these
methods is working with any resolution
in general but the model itself is
typically have some base resolution that
is trained on
and if you I think the regularized fine
tuning is one of the best one for the
generic case in terms of like uh in in a
regular regularized fine-tuning you have
more control over your training and in
this case I think you will
um be able to
uh increase the resolution uh
more easier than the other ways because
for example for the textual inversion
it's uh
typically it's not very easy to change
the original resolution for the
Dreamboat it somehow works but not very
well for the lore and Hyper Network
since I think this is a second and third
one so the first one I I will recommend
the regular regularized by tuning for
the psycho Mount Laura for the short one
is a hyperness because yeah this is a
most generic three ones yeah but the
regular regularized fine tuning is the
most generic one and
yeah and
um
produce can uh the the you'll have very
fine graded control over your uh fine
tuning so you can change the aspect
ratio of the model itself even with this
method is possible
deployment like automated cicd oh uh in
this case all the similar uh just the
difference in the storage phase so
because this is a trainings method so
fine-tuning is a training phase yeah
this is not related to the inference but
the storage is can affect your
deployment a lot because yeah sometimes
it's not easy to have the very large
amount of uh storage yeah so in this
case it's only only the storage affects
the deployment in general
uh almost everything the only
restriction the textual inversion is
sometimes
um
not
as powerful to capture this concept
sometimes you just don't have this
concept in a or your original model yeah
in this case Dreamboat can learn
something but the textual inversion
can't yeah because you can't find this
if you are don't have this in a model
but this is a typically it's very rare
Concepts yeah because this is a
very large models and they're trained on
a very large consoles but yeah sometimes
it it happened yeah so for faces for
example the sexual immersion
yeah it works but I think yeah yeah it
works but slightly I think uh worse than
the Dreamboat because the faces is a
some specific Concepts that for example
stable diffusion is not learned very
well yeah it's just not represent good
faces yeah
yeah
yep
what are the backgrounds of these
noodles uh what kind of mod it can be
everything hypothetically but yeah in a
majority of uh cases is the stable
diffusion yeah so but uh it's possible
to adopt this uh adapt these models to
the other models but the only problem is
that the for example dalit on the
Imagine is not open source but for
example there is a the cacao brain is
publishing the this Carlo model that is
open source implementation of dalito and
yeah these things is work with Carlo
yeah
can you open the text World in Russian
slightly
I'm not sure that I have a question
uh I think it comes from the very this
Laura thing is very old so this is a the
first if I remember correctly the first
usage of this low rank adaptation for
optimization purposes is starting from
these large language models so yeah this
is just intuition that if you will
factorize these best Matrix to the to
one uh to smaller ones you just give the
speed up
yeah uh it's very interesting thing that
the the speed is actually
um
uh yeah the the only thing that you
affect with this
uh wrong thing so this is a the speed
and the storage yeah in the main case so
you can the
uh this is a large trade-off yeah
between uh three different things so the
first thing this is a uh your data set
size that is represent your amount of
new information that you uh you're
trying to inject to your model and
between the speed and storage uh things
yeah uh so uh typically the method to
find the correct rank is you are trying
to get the highest possible rank that
the lowest possible rank that is can
overfit your data and iteratively try to
decrease it to achieve the speed and
storage yeah so this is a logic the
typical Logic for finding the rank
for this case yeah so
thank you
foreign